[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
another episode of careful boys we have
chris sosa in the hot seat
how this works is that you were asked a
series of questions that begin it's very
very cold and easy to answer and then it
goes into the realm of like how the hell
do i get out of here i can't answer any
more of these my reputation is going
down the drain ooh okay perfect so
everybody has fun we like to start off
with bart because bart is an artisan of
like the coldest question you could
possibly think of
go ahead bart
what's the difference
between
i always laughed
already because i've seen this so many
times from this angle and i can see his
thought process where he's puckered it's
always like this
takes a big deep breath and then the
first half of the question allows him to
buy time and then what comes out
afterwards i could never get and you got
you just let him buy an extra 10 seconds
so thank you distracted me sorry
if you were given the assignment
sorry to draw these two creatures okay
and you have to
draw it where people know that they're
different okay how would you do it and
these are the two creatures one
is a zebra
and the other one is a horse with
stripes
oh
how would you showcase to the world
that these are completely different
animals i switch it for i do the zebra
is going to be uh vertical lines and the
and the horse with stripes is going to
be horizontal lines so it's going to be
like the
smart man yeah yeah yeah i break it down
like that because then because then
you'll be like like you see a zebra
zebra oh she's the zebra you see the the
horse with horizontal lines like like
strikes you like yo the horn has been in
jail the horde yeah
[Laughter]
that good for a question like that the
question was i was like that's hard that
was like that's a tough question but you
went
i got this easy switch the line i think
i've seen you since uh before covet dude
like you you moved uh back to texas yeah
for uh during that time yeah i was out
there uh uh 2020. i i really like during
the pandemic i think it started like
around like february out here in the
world and then like i stayed until like
june then i moved to houston in in july
and i was just like you know the saving
money the whole situation like yeah i
could still make money from from uh you
know work from home and stuff so cause
there were no shows right yeah no shows
and stuff but i was you know producing
content online and stuff so you know i
was still able to make la money but
living in
houston household living yeah prices and
you started a um production company out
there yo yeah i mean i look i'm not even
trying to like gas y'all but like y'all
truly inspiration you know saying like
y'all made we're i'm in your studio and
i remember the feeling of being in here
and i was like yo you gotta aim higher
bro really no man no no i'm being honest
bro classic joke i'm being honest for
real bro it was like oh snap it's
possible you can have you can make your
own studio have your own crew and really
run your stuff so you know the same
thing with like kev on stage and you
know even you know the tyler perry's and
kevin hart's like they have a studio so
i always wanted i was like
the opportunity fell on my lap to do
that for houston from my city and and
then specifically the town that i grew
up in that's where i put it and uh you
know uh what is it like for the market
it probably wasn't the smartest to put
it where the town that i was in because
everything really happened like in the
city in the loop they would call it like
that's where like all the the music the
the the the food and all the it's
probably in the city but i put it in the
north side like my side of town you know
say it like oh and it was cool i'm glad
that i did it had some dope experiences
out of it what kind of content did you
guys produce so uh it's multimedia so we
had a cyclorama uh room we had a dance
studio and we had a podcast room uh
which was also a music studio too and so
um we had podcasters come in and you
know rent it out you know every week and
we had a comedy shows and so
the way i designed it which was crazy
that i even designed this building like
every wall in this day like i didn't
know what i was doing oh yeah you guys
had stand-up shows yeah yeah so i put up
i put up shows because wow
the way the the the the psych room and
the and the uh the cyclorama room and
this dance studio was separated by a
roll-up garage door and so uh you roll
that up it turns into an event space
right and so i use the cyclorama wall as
the stage and uh fit like 50 seats in
there put a dj in there in the lighting
i'm really big on lighting so i
definitely set the vibe
for it and um i had dope comedy shows it
was so cool that i had homies from l.a
like fly out and
and headline you know say it like
comedians that you would only go to the
houston improv to perform there's not
really like big comedy clubs to perform
at and created the spaceport yeah so
then they hit they came to create a
space houston oh man you know say and
and they came to humble texas that's
that's the town it's called humble and
uh it's just wild to hear like you know
you know matt rife is that humble you
know what i'm saying like it's cool yeah
that right show me yours yes yes one of
my boys yo so uh and then even dave was
talking about davidson was talking about
like doing uh a live uh genius brain out
there you know what i'm saying oh sick
yeah hell yeah yo but uh we have it
survived for it for a year and that had
some crazy momentum happen ironically
the most momentum that i've ever gotten
towards my entertainment career happened
when i moved out of l.a because you came
here for that absolutely and then when
you went back home
it uh your your fault everything got
better like yeah yeah it was it was uh
it was something that i didn't even know
that i i needed like that uh that that
move back home i didn't realize the the
uh the holes that were made like being
out here you know you're out here to
grind you're already hustle get it you
know network and all go to all these
things and it's like you kind of like
beat yourself up you don't even know
what you are you're just like this is
the motions that i have to go through
this is what this is what it means to
chase your dream when i went back home
i'm back with my fam you know i'm eating
better i got this studio now creating my
own visions so it really made me
stronger as a person as an entertainer
um as a business owner like even as a
family like a family member with my fam
i got to really get like closer with my
with my with my people so uh and i grew
my hair out that's a whole another thing
too everybody tripped out when they saw
him when i came back they were like yo
what's this this look bro i didn't even
know that was you and this and that and
i didn't cut my hair the whole time i
was out there i just had a whole
actually i busted it when i moved i just
got wet i went i had this this look you
know i'm saying with the shitty look
right yeah yeah he's a [ __ ] look yeah
and i just did it
yeah yeah yeah when i went to the barber
shop straight up yo and and you know
what's crazy is that like i'm like i'm
like hella like uh what is it i'm i was
kind of insecure about the the hair as
far as like you know with the with the
fade and stuff like that you want to
make sure your hair is right and that's
kind of like the culture i was brought
up being cleaned up yeah yeah yeah so
like doing this was was big for me
because it's just like it's a commitment
to go through the ugly stage and the
hats yeah you gotta get that in between
done yeah the in between that's true
yeah you know bro you got the ponytail
bro like that midstage though it's yeah
the flop haircut
just like this
just doesn't look good for all just i've
had it bro for real i look like a
lesbian protester dude yeah
but that but that's it in some places
you know it's kind of fire but houston
was the best thing that ever happened to
me going back you don't say it and then
now like because that caught like a lot
of attention of what i got going on um
it was uh zoom meetings it was like from
la from networks and then or masculinity
or just asking like what is it that you
want to make what do you want to what
are you interested in and what's and i'm
just like wait what yeah like i've never
these opportunities just like probably
because they saw that you could make
something yourself yeah you agree yeah
yeah yeah that's huge man were you like
i'm ready to get those holes back in my
heart in la again
i got it i got it all filled right now
so i'm like now i can go back and like i
could take it you know rest again
honestly i really take it as like a as a
round two i take it as a rematch yeah
that's nice yeah hell yeah coming back
to la and so far i've been i've been
i've been hitting the ground running you
know it's like it's a it's a dope wave
that i've been riding that's dope you
still got your uh creative space in
houston no man i shut it down bro the
whole thing yeah so i gotta also give
y'all y'alls flowers man uh uh as as a
business owner
it's hard really hard man and and and i
didn't have a team you know saying i
didn't have investors i everything that
i did out of christmas
respect though for that yeah yeah like
my shows and other stuff like i would
break even on my shows like and my thing
was like i just love putting on a dope
show i wasn't even mad bro i was i was
paying everybody off and then i left
with myself like gas money you know you
did all that and you weren't go funding
everybody oh see that's respect yeah i
didn't you know you didn't become a
gofundme handout dude
i know a couple of those guys yeah and
and and uh um i just uh yeah got it got
it the it was crazy because during the
hardest times i was really just like man
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] did i
just put myself into what am i doing
what is happening but i was just like
let me just keep moving let me just as
long as i keep moving instead of just
like sitting there just like moping
around something's gonna pop off and
then i got a crazy email you know from
uh from a great a good friend of mine
but we haven't spoken a while until like
february but issa rae hits me wow and
she's like is this still your email and
i'm like isa is this still my email
it can be it's gonna be forever yeah i'm
like yo what and then from then on like
it was just like you know she was really
looking out and really you know bouncing
like booty hunter yahoo.com
[Laughter]
yo
yeah yeah you should check if that
email's still out there yeah you can
still grab it bro i think yeah i'll just
add my year after it booty 193.
you know
yeah
hell yeah bro yeah man but yeah i'm i'm
back now it feels right you know it
feels right and uh i feel like that was
the last little like let go because
that's my baby you know saying like i
created something from nothing i loved
that place that was my creative space
like really kind of on the selfish side
of it i had somewhere to really like
really work on my stuff create and paint
and like people didn't realize that like
a a lot of the things that come i'm i
i'm multifaceted in the other like
worlds of art like with with designing
with painting with dancing i got back
dancing that [ __ ] felt good yeah let's
go yeah man for sure she was a boxers
too yeah when you went
back
home did that feel like defeat from la
oh hell yeah bro that was a i would have
just blamed covet and been like man
coping yeah
that was the thing i was trying to be i
was my ego was really like that what was
keeping me in la during covert i was
being like nah i'm not gonna let the
pandemic like you know make me go back
home like [ __ ] that i'm still making
money i'm i can still do be here my
brother was the one that was just like
yo like let's just make this i know
you're getting your ass kicked over
there you know what i'm saying yeah and
they're and they're like yeah and and
they're like yo you don't have to pay
rent stay with us you know it's not like
you you can be good and and so i decided
to instead of my like paying rent that i
was paying i was living i was actually
living like it was my first time like
having like a luxury apartment i finally
felt like now in l.a in l.a i was like
nice i did it you know you did it here
yeah and so i was like i don't want to
[ __ ] let this go i finally figured
out like i could like finally live you
know pretty good you know um but i let
it go and i when i went to houston and
did my thing and i paid that's pretty
much the same amount what i was paying
for this one bedroom apartment for my
entire studio yeah straight up yeah
those places are so different yeah
super different yeah man so it's still
cheaper for me to own a home in vegas
and fly out here and go back than to
rent a place here and shut up yeah
that's wild isn't that crazy i believe
it though it's just insane you know what
i mean but hey so tell us uh what the
heck is this uh dominic usher oh bro yes
so i
i did this uh i did dominican usher back
when i was in houston too uh still like
every now and then making uh making
content doing these voice-overs and
stuff on my social media and so usher uh
he was promoting that he was gonna be
having a residency during his first run
of his residency in vegas and so he was
on good morning america and he was
singing acapella but he was singing his
classics right so he was doing the like
uh when you feel it in your body you
found somebody who and he's doing it all
sounds beautiful right and so i'm
watching i'm a huge i have to also say
i'm a huge usher fan who isn't honestly
like i i grew up like i mean obviously i
love michael jackson but like for me as
a kid i grew up on usher being my guy
who was the uh pop star dancer good you
know good looking women also like this
guy's that was my guy and so i'm
watching it and uh you know after
watching it i'll just kind of like walk
around and i do this accident right i
talk like this all the time sometimes i
can you know what do the entire day or
i'm just like well actually what do you
mean i don't have an accent you sound
funny you know and so i just started
singing like that i was just like
somebody who
and i made myself like laughs when i did
that when you freddie
and uh i went for it and i just made the
voiceover hey yo literally it just
popped like that that video popped and
then i did another uh usher classic and
then another usher classic and i just
had like a a seven part series i loved
all of them dude they're great the
awesome you know what i'm saying your
dub overs are [ __ ] sick yes
i think the first one i saw was a jew
guy that you got it back
that's the one yeah yeah
i wanna hear you through him bro
yeah so and so uh so so that was so that
was the original one he was it was a red
background that was original that's the
original one yeah and so and so then i
like uh i like to for i like to kind of
think that my my bits are like classic
so i would i would then like leave it
alone like that was my raw like i'm
gonna
i'm not
that alone and let that and let that sit
yeah yeah and so i chilled on doing
dominic industries even people being
like yo you gotta bring do dominic
nestor again dude
i couldn't wait i was like oh he's doing
another one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
so then he made the he did a tiny desk
yeah and this was like two weeks ago
he dropped it right and you know it was
on my i was just scrolling instagram i'm
with my cousin right now i'm staying
over there and i remember i go oh snap
bro i sure dropped a tiny desk and like
as a fan i was like it's a big deal yeah
yeah yeah he was like what i said yo
guess who else dropped a tiny desk he
goes who and i he was like well chris
brown and i was like nah dominican usher
and he was like here we go and i kid you
not you know i just went to the room and
i just like i i watched this whole tiny
desk and then i saw the moment that i
that i wanted to do it on and it was the
moment where he was just thanking his
his fans and his inside his singers and
this is what it why i do this and it's
really for my brothers and and the love
and the passion and so whenever he was
doing i was like oh i'm about to kill
him
this is for my brothers
for the music
you know sometimes and and i wanted to
add a lot of like dominican you know
feels of like you know saying the
platinum
you know saying with mango and stuff
like that and so we have this state
where it's like uh male ketchup it's
literally just a mix of mayo and ketchup
and that's a dip that we may catch
and so i and so i i did the i did the
the bit and it was just that last little
nugget at the end where i was just like
i honestly i was kind of getting over
the voiceover i was like let me just add
a little dominican little deal and then
get out of it right and uh that happened
to be the best part of like wow
life you know what you got to get and it
matched with his lips
yeah that's the thing
that's one of my favorite things that's
what that's my little secret with the
with the with the voiceovers like like
got a magic jack make it match yo make
it match their lips even if it's not
what they're saying look at their lips
and see like put it on mute don't watch
the videos with the audio yeah that's
why it's the watch
and just read their lips and be like it
looks like he's saying ketchup you know
and then the next word just worked where
i said mayonnaise and his mouth is going
you know what i'm saying so it just
worked you got the ketchup you got the
mayonnaise
life is like male ketchup life is like
america
you know there's a harvest which is you
know you know you understand there was
that one too where he was like uh
um
like he was in a roller skating rink
yeah oh yeah just like skating around
and just the way he was moving just
looks so latin
so with the voiceover
don't lead your girl around me true
player for real
and then he's like glad
and so the tiny desk i i dropped it he
lit the like the the when tiny desk
dropped it the tiny like my voiceover
went out like 30 minutes later that's
amazing like right on it
you don't want to do the full 20 minutes
honestly though i ain't gonna lie i
thought about that but then like doing
like a patreon situation where it's just
like i got the whole concert the entire
thing from top to bottom but i also want
to have like i have my boys who do music
and stuff who can like finesse beats
because i actually wanted to actually
sound like the bands behind me and you
know i mean yeah really go in the
background you gotta go you got to do
the full thing yeah yeah that might get
over a million views watch this you know
what i'm saying like really hitting oh
dude you have to mess it up that would
be a [ __ ] banger for real why don't
you do it dominican biden
oh
there's no dialogue
uh
we're in a lot of trouble what's going
on right now but uh we can we're trying
our best we're doing what we gotta do
because at the end of the day
america is like um
[Laughter]
i was like yo
that gave me the stamp because i was
like man honestly i was really feeling
like what if because i love him so much
i'm like what if he [ __ ] hates this
what if he's like this is annoying yo
like stop with your [ __ ] yo you know
what i mean he's doing his he's doing
his promo and i'm over here just like
[ __ ] your promo yo
nah that's homage though you know
you don't i feel like when i watch it
you doing that in my mind i don't think
it's like oh he's hating on usher it's
like no it's just
you're blending your world and his world
together you know it's funny it helps
his sales yeah
so yeah he actually used he so the when
he when it dropped his his response to
the feedback of the tiny desk his his
first tweet out after that came out was
the retweet of my video
and he said he says thanks for tuning in
to my tiny desk gracias
though
i got usher to speak spanish you know
because of the dominican usher gave him
a leia he took you on with his momentum
like together yes yo laughing emoji so
that's nice so i was like cool that was
like the stamp on of like oh cool i know
that he's uh uh [ __ ] with it yeah and
then and then though he uh uh he has a
uh one of his guys
and his team follows me and reached out
to me
being like yo i got you know i roll
usher i'm i'm i'm driving when he's on
tour and it's like he's just letting me
know like
it's legit whatever and he's just like
yo like oh oh let's let's let's connect
and so we got on the phone and he was
like yo i sure loves it i'm like for
real he's like he's like take me on tour
i'll open for him i'm like just give me
just give me a minute on the residency
imagine if dominican usher makes an
appearance dude
honestly it's not that crazy it's not
that really not that crazy or even if he
does a concert like his first song and
you're backstage and he lip syncs to
what you're doing
honestly if usher doesn't do it he's a
[ __ ] idiot bro hey bro i think that
might be the real idiot if you don't
take chris osa with you hey
your move ball's in your quarters hey yo
they're saying it but uh for real please
that'd be tight that means i'd be hella
cool that'd be
he said that his girl's puerto rican he
said and said that he said that she she
sometimes randomly will throw a
dominican usher at him so it's an inside
joke in the house
[Music]
[Music]
you